[Music]
good morning everyone thank you so much
for inviting me until I saw pleasure to
be with you this morning like Jordan
mentioned most of my time I look for
five years at Microsoft most of my time
I spend with our customers mostly large
enterprises in different verticals my
background is mostly computer science
then I move to the data space I've been
doing cloud computing as you can see for
more than 10 years and I really really
would like to sit with companies
customers helping them to solve business
problems mostly for data science
perspective on top of cloud of course on
Microsoft cloud era and today I just
wanted to share a little bit different
experiences and technical tips or
practices that I've seen different
companies adopting to make their data
science processes and teams a bit more
agile or helping them to deliver best
business value or more agility
especially as you grow in your data
science practice to make it more
effective and also possible at scale
it's a little bit the idea I must tell
you that it's few things in my
presentation that you might don't agree
it might be chalked that's great I
invite you to drop me an email or
connect with me in LinkedIn and as
Georgie mention in the end it is also
some time that you can make any
questions and discuss different
perspectives but those are just a few
things that I wanted to highlight so the
first thing I see in organizations owns
more large organizations large companies
is that the last few years of course
machine learning is nothing something
new I think is just becoming more
popular more adopted for different facts
I think cloud computing is one of them
open-source is another one people more
skilled on that space as well but I see
it there is a big trend on the data
science teams because initially data
mining might might have been with
cetaceans a very individual job so
people were doing few statistical models
perceived models on their laptop and
connected of course with the business
but more and more I really seen the
conversations with the teams I have from
chief data officer head of analytics
data science teams and business
Steam's that is really shared sport okay
and by that that means that there is
also a change in process that needs to
be in place okay first thing I did I
think coming from top is that of course
company needs to have a data strategy of
course I will not bother you with that
topic but that's extremely important
then over time of course when you have
data more data needed for your business
drive let's say culture of data-driven
decisions
that's definitely what teams want to do
and then there's a few roles that play
via discussion this slide is just a
subset of that today we're going to
focus most of my practical tips I want
to give you our of course going to be
focused on later scientists but of
course as you know they was just talk
before and as you know there's a
different track on date engineering
that's a big part of the job before you
can start to to get and work with the
data I forgot to do one introduce myself
to to ask a few questions to you so I
know better who's in his team who's the
data scientist by the way ok that's
close to 50% that's great
late engineer ok some people skip the
other track managers ok and who works
for a start-up works for large
enterprise organizations I feel like 50%
of all my questions
ok that's great so like I said there's a
lot of processes that need to be in
place in the end of my presentation I
have a link to one of the options to
adopt process for data science from end
to end because that's not just about one
use cases about getting the business
with new processes in adopting them so
from now on without going into detail
with all the roles using these slides is
really about what I think you can do
practically to improve your data science
practices just 5 tips hopefully they
will fit in half an hour
and there is some demos in the middle
first one of course data science is
extremely interactive job right you
start with the business problem you get
some data you start to build models with
your favorite programming language your
favorite frameworks sometimes using more
sophisticated methods as deep learning
but you don't need to then of course
most of the time is really about tuning
your your models the parameters do more
experimentation
greater machine learning pipelines and
then of course that doesn't finish
that's why I had a slide before about
teams when you have a purdue model you
need to have a process to deploy it into
production and get it integrated with
your your your applications and
end-users okay so one of the the things
I've seen that I think it's very
important especially when it's not one
person is five ten people doing data
science in in a company I sometimes
across different departments some people
might doing I might be doing few codes
some people my doing more visual things
is really about every time you run
machine learning experiments or every
time you do some different trying and
new algorithm trying new parameters make
sure that those experiments are tracked
okay because first you have a record of
everything that is happening in your
data science practice especially when
you have a team when you're doing
different projects that's really
important and second because you want to
find what what is better over time and
sometimes you don't remember exactly how
did you achieve that I've seen people
doing that so that's also for
reproducibility so some point in time
you want to know what how did you
achieve some result with which
parameters let me show you a very simple
example what it means of course using
the cloud in this case it's interesting
because I'm still using my laptop as you
can see this is Jupiter on my laptop so
I'm still running locally the only thing
I'm doing is importing a small SDK
Python SDK in this case just checking
the version connecting to my workspace
that's the service that we leverage in
Azure for Azure machine learning those
are just some metals behind the scenes
that are not relevant sorry
there was this one actually that those
are just the configuration then I am
what what I'm doing is I'm say I'm
running an experiment this is really the
right one okay you start with this one
for sure okay now it's
okay so I'm saying I'm doing a training
I'm just experiment name and luckily
this is my training file not going to
bother with the details this is standard
for data scientists data set from
scikit-learn this is just my training
file I've just now seen our library and
I'm saying I want to use my laptop
environment so in this case of course
Conda to have easier your life yes I'm
just saying that I want to submit this
to my environment once more this is my
laptop I don't need to get out of it I
will be running my experiment with a few
seconds of course it's a simple model
and now I can even see how it iterates
over time you can see this is really
fast because it's a simple problem meet
rating over time my alpha now MSE are
changing okay this is nice I already see
what is happening here but back to my
original idea the idea is that you have
a place where you can generalize all
your experiments that you have run what
I'm doing now is swapping to a graphical
view whenever that basically these all
the runs I've run in my laptop right now
I have a graphical way to see over time
everything that happened behind the
scenes okay in this case I did just a
few iterations but I can already see the
what are the key metrics I want to track
in overtime how they perform once more
it's a very small example then I'm going
to run something a bit more complicated
but it's already a best practice
secondly
I find the right notebook this time
[Music]
secondly I'm doing exactly the same
thing but of course we we said that we
want to leverage the clouds and still
give it the resolve of tracking
experiments what I'm doing now is
running a same experiment but saying I
want to have some extra power of course
my laptop has a limit of CPUs of course
in memory I want something bigger I want
to be a bigger virtual machine in the
cloud so I'm creating a new experiment
that I call it turn on remote VM passing
all the parameters getting the datasets
I want to bother with the details once
more I have a file with my training
script very similar to the previous ones
then I'm attaching it to the machine
running it I've run it this morning so I
can save some minutes in dream
representation as you can see these are
all the details of alpha MSC and all my
Condor packages within the environment
when it's finished we can go back to the
portal and now in this case as you can
see this one - I think 5 mm 5 seconds
per iteration our credentials are
expired when what happens when you
change I peace give it a second
okay as you can see now I see for every
run in my code course I'm swapping
parameters how long it take and what was
the values I'm tracking for MST so I can
very easily come here and see which one
I had the lower MSE okay
so this was my first tip as you can see
using Azure machine learning or
potentially other ways you have a
centralized place where you just log
your your code no matter where you're
running on your laptop but bigger
virtual machine with CPUs GPUs just are
able to track what are you doing in what
your team is doing okay so that's one
first tip I will start with second one I
think is extremely useful even for
professional scientists which might be
more than 50% of this room is to
leverage what you already have out of
the box in the cloud so there is this
concept of cognitive computing which is
basically the idea is to build api's
pre-trained models that are consumed as
restful api is where we embed some of
the capabilities of humans that's all
it's called cognitive right so you have
fusion capabilities speaking abilities
understanding capabilities what you see
here is just a very small subset of what
is a value as a cognitive services we
call them in Azure cloud but basically
the idea you have a model that has been
trained most of them are deep neural
networks trained with a very large data
set to solve one or multiple problems
and you can just consume them why a
mission is to professionally to
scientists because sometimes when it's
starting a small project or a small
problem that you want to fix sometimes
it's not worth the time or an investment
to to train your full model from scratch
because it you just want to validate
that you can achieve something or you
don't have enough data to train that
model so one way is maybe start with
those EP eyes more and more over time
those API is start to be more
customizable so you can basically modify
the external layers of the neural
network okay so one example of a
cognitive service is for forms so you
have set of forms like medical check-up
text declaration or any kind of document
actually and basically using one of
those cognitive services I know it's a
video basically just sending the
document a PDF there
it's just scans it detects tables
disguises new voice could be also
recieved of all fabio and basically just
tries to figure out what's the
information there and extract it as a
JSON so you know exactly what is a table
there what fills and so on that's that
becomes unstructured into structure okay
once more thing about doing all this
from scratch
in the data science process two more
things I wanted to show you where you
can leverage cognitive computing
so these are the five categories I
mention vision is one of them so few
things that you can do with these
services for example analyzing image
okay in this case I'm seeing a picture
of a scene it's detecting people it's
attacking there is a way in the trend so
I said okay why don't we try with a
different thing okay so I went to my
browser and I saw there is some nice
picture of the day of penguins so I took
a screenshot of that picture and see how
it performs there same picture I showed
you sink into the cognitive service so
it's able to identify a lot more thing
that I mentioned to you it can also
identify people if there are their
emotions their gender their age the
position of the ball is a lot more
things it can detect but in this case
I'm just sending one picture I just
found this morning in my laptop if the
connection ok as you can see it detected
Akshay penguin so it's actually trying
to identify some objects and not just
the Penguins of course we have the
binding boxes of that and you have a few
keywords animal outdoors no group bird
and so on so that's actually pretty good
second example I wanted to show you is I
think a pretty complicated data science
problem which is detect and written text
okay I actually been in a few projects
with companies with data scientists to
write them from scratch and they are not
easy to tackle so this morning I just
wrote this with my hand written which is
not the most nice-looking one so but
it's mine so what I'm doing is I'm just
sending this to this API and saying this
is handwritten
and as you can see even though I don't
have the most nice-looking handwritten
it takes exactly what I've wrote it's
more the result is a Jason you can even
find the location of each word with the
bounding box and so on so those are just
a few examples there's a lot more of
cognitive services I want to show you
because once more sometimes is not word
to start from building your models from
scratch just by leverage things that are
pre-trained and combine them with your
your own train and will build them into
your data science pipeline same thing
for text analytics there's a couple of
good one translation and so on okay next
one I want to mention to you is a even
though you might be very professional it
incident is to your love code
I love code personally sometimes it's
worth - don't start always with code and
for that I'm referring when you have a
small business coming to you with a
small project I just want to validate it
just give you some date and you want to
see if that that probably is feasible or
not with a data science approach
sometimes it is easy to look at
graphical interfaces so what I'm going
to show you to you is a possibility my
screen allows me okay interesting I have
one screen there in a different one
Auto fullscreen we're back so one idea
here will be to use a graphical
interface to quickly mock up a data
science party it is also very effective
for non-professional scientists
typically citizen data scientists
business data scientist someone who
really understands the business as
understanding of a machine learning
problem so there's a graphical interface
to do that basically as you can see you
just start to drag and drop boxes this
one actually it's already pretty done I
wanted to show you from scratch but we
are short on time so basically I'm
importing a data set in this case I have
some simple data just imported here
I connect it to a split data to split my
training in test data set
I'm picking one of the many available
algorithms there as you can see this for
classification closing in regression and
just pick one of them of course I can
fine tune some of the parameters then
I'm scoring it I'm getting the result
I'm getting the test set and evaluating
the model okay to prove to you that this
works let me just go to the experiment
that has been run already when you run
basically specify what kind of compute
you want to ever behind the scenes
depending on how complex is a problem
and once is there basically we just can
you can come here and see first look at
the data set
Socrates food once more let the business
data set just want to look at it with
some statistics you get it out of the
box and you run your model and then in
this case I just want to visualize the
results of the scoring with my score
labels
another very interesting thing here that
you can do after testing your after
training your model you can click click
on the plug web service and literally
with a few clicks I won't be doing it
now because I've done it before you're
going to deploy your model as a
predictive web service okay let me show
you that I've done that just before to
save some time so I have n points means
was deployed from that study I'll show
you before
and as you can see there is a scoring
URI which I can connect to and make
predictions if you actually go back here
sorry if I go back to web services it's
exactly what I wanted to show you before
so our connection is not helping me so
bear with me
this is my deployed model I've shown you
before it's basically to predict the
value of a car based on a set of inputs
like the age of the car or many
kilometers what was the initial price so
this is the deploying web service is
deployed as a container because that's
the industry during these days so this
is are the variables I'm sending to the
to the British model and I'm just
sending those ones connecting to the end
point and getting a result back and the
result of the prediction in this case is
the value of the car okay it gives you a
sort of the box some code symbols to
connect by yourself or if you really
want to connect at low level it has also
the RESTful API specification so you
have seen we didn't just in this case
very little minutes because we don't
have much time but how can you leverage
a graphical interface to build
predictive models I'd forget to mention
that you can also bring your own code so
RN patent can be in the middle of your
floater so you can still code and
basically auto deploy that as a mall so
I think it's a very valid way to
prototype quickly and sometimes even to
take your experiments further and faster
okay
next thing next tip I wanted to show you
is about leveraging automated machine
learning anyone using it on your day to
day plastic said already one person okay
that's a good sign
so tomato machine learning basically
tries to make your life as a data
scientist a little bit easier I don't
know when you start doing a pretty model
there's a lot of time behind the scenes
of showing different algorithms
different parameters and fine-tune them
that can be really really time-consuming
let me skip a few animations and show
you how it works in our graphical
interface
the idea behind the scene is of course
as a data scientist of course you know
better than anyone
all to build models the best models but
it can kind of automate part of your of
your process basically testing a lot of
different algorithms test them in
parallel and fine-tune all the
parameters which I think can save you a
lot of time and by the end of the day
after you've run these kind of
experiments you can still retrieve the
model and see what are the variables
that are more impactful and based on
that still keep carrying on your your
job I think the connection is not really
helping me a lot
I prefer to show you the real thing than
just animation let's destroy otherwise I
have a animation I can show you as well
okay
it's basically I've run it before to
save some time basically providing a
dataset which I'll show you in a second
I'm just specifying the name of the
experiment and what is the compute
behind the scenes I'm loading the data
set this case is a banking data set a
public one what basically is about
trying to detect if a specific loan or
offer I want to make to the customer you
will take it or not you can see the
variables age job lot of them it can
very easily say for example don't
include I don't know day of the week
that might not be included okay
can look at the profile of the data per
variable and then where the automated
machine learning Evan is here basically
I'm saying what metric I want to to
track on in this case I'll take a UC
waitis how long I want this to be
running because it can be running for
lots of time and also of course the cost
of its running is impacted to you or the
max of interactions you wonder what kind
of validation you want to make number of
cross validations the concurrency which
is interesting you can start to
parallelize things and save some time
and basically a lot of algorithms that
you want to try or if there's something
that is specifically don't want to test
it you basically say I don't use those
two SVM and in your SSS VM okay after
that it submits of course needs a few
mins to get started and once it's run as
you can see these are iterations over
time and this is the metric am tracking
AUC so I can see your for each other
eaten first
how long it took to train with one which
of them and then in this case I want to
see which one performed well which was
the voting in Samba which was actually
the last one there on top right okay
very interesting to automate part of
your machine learning processes
okay
so my last tip might be the one that
might be a bit more outside of where
you've seen on data science process if
not I'll be very happy
which is really bad helping you to build
kind of if you want to call a machine
learning factory basically being able to
chip more machine learning models into
production make sure that they are
tracked and that you can detect that
they are decaying performance over time
you can automatically retrain them
that's kind of the idea of course for
that it requires I think a big change in
processes and of course the tools behind
them the idea is to embrace the concept
of DevOps everyone talks about DevOps
these days really about the iterative
experiment fast sprint quick fail fast
and I have a complete feedback loop
that's the idea with general software
software development we already using
machine learning world it's slightly
more complicated than deploying your web
application because of the data and the
models and the performance and that we
know that over time models will decay
accuracy when they are deployed ok so
there's a few things that I think are
important if you want to embrace this
concept of machine learning operations
which is basically of course
reproducibility that's why I start with
the experimenting the invalidation of
course automation machine learning might
help you there but that's an optional
step and of course although ID Pro
models and now I already trained them so
from a very generic point of view the
idea is you have data scientists like
most of you guys training your models
which will be able to have a central
place where you have what we call a
continuous integration continuous
deployment pipeline which means that
your code is basically every time you
change your code or make a comment you
say behind the scenes I want to
automatically for example run some tests
on my model in the polymer model into
pre-production or test environments I
think it's really interesting because of
course it brings extra engineering
skills to data scientists we also give
you the capability to really deploy your
models test them and potentially if you
have some applications or even
dashboards that you want to connect your
operative models and see how it looks
like and show you to the business I
think it's a really good way so that's
the main idea secondly over time the
models will decay in performance so the
ideas that we collect the metrics of the
models we centralize them in some place
in
we are will to retrain the model of
fully to improve it or if it doesn't
improve I at least I should be able to
detect that and in worse in extreme
cases take it out of production okay
without going further I will just show
you a small demo this some slides about
each and every steps but let me just
show you a demo in this case we use a
specific tool for DevOps we need to use
for machine learning processes so here I
have a very simple pipeline that I've
defined before machine learning pipeline
for continuous integration let me show
you what it looks like
so what i'm doing here is defining a few
steps one of them is i'm just thing i
want to use python and then the most
relevant one for data science is I have
a few scripts in Python as you can see
which is one is training that's very
similar to what I showed in the
beginning then have another script to
say I want to evaluate my model once my
model is evaluated I will register that
with the Central Register for models so
I can track all my models into
production and then deploying I will
generate a container to potential deploy
that okay I've learned that before and
basically text in this case I think
three or four minutes let's do one
remember this is every time I save my
code or I commit something this happens
behind this seam so it doesn't affect my
job as a scientist but as you can see
for every step starting let's say maybe
with the start training on local local
is some machine remotely in this case
then well before it was installing
packages then I'm running evaluate the
model just takes it ten seconds
registering the model and in this case
the interesting part may be for you here
is this line it says that the model I
have currently in production has this
amount of MSE and anyone has that one so
based on that has some logic to say I
take it into production or do I just
keep it okay
and finally when the build because it
was just how to make the build of your
code is done I might have a way to
release that into production in this
case I've deployed it as a single
container behind the scenes it took I
think five minutes so once more is a API
exposed I can consume it and if I want
to take it into production I could make
a trigger and of course production
things are very sensitive so it might
need a human to go there in the process
that's kind of the eye
okay just shoo shoo one last minute I
know we want to be quick on a lot of
different concepts but basically the
idea is that as Microsoft we've been
doing of course machine learning for
more than 25 years we've been investing
very hard and a lot on bringing
artificial intelligence and
sophisticated machine learning tools for
any kind of profile from professional
scientists citizen data scientist
application developers want just to
build on me I that's the key with our
platform my experience like I taught
with big companies and you see names of
big companies in the business impact
they add with adopting some of these
processes and tools I think it can be
very big specially when you think about
scale scale from data science
perspective it's also scale from
installation of your machine learning
models my closing talks and you're gonna
have access to the slides
two things one of them is read about the
data science project is really similar
to Chris BM but I think more more modern
if you want to try user machine learning
I think it's extremely interesting
because of some of the features and
today we didn't go very deep but there's
a lot of other concepts that I think are
worth to make your data science course
even better
particularly one of them is detecting
the testing data drift manual automatic
on when you have models in the
production a big question I get very
often from customers is I'll do
interpret interpret the models behind
the scenes so there's also capability to
have modern interpret interpret ability
and of course leverage the hardware GPUs
FPGAs are really cost performance
efficient when you have complex
workloads such as deep learning ok and
with that I'll think we are on top of
the time I appreciate your time feel
free to ask any questions now or later
or reach out to me thank you thank you
for speech how is your system your UI
interface how it is suitable for use in
deep learning models such as based on
tensor flow framework is it possible to
load some / train models from
metafiles or something like that thank
you thank you I didn't go too much into
that detail today the system you've seen
which is on Azure it's really tries to
be a non open 18 system which means that
we just want to level to the let you
live
your favorite tools by that I mean you
can use any open-source framework
including pi torch tensorflow
or any of them so you still control your
complete your code the frameworks when
to run so it's completely compatible
with that on top of that optionally like
you've seen I was running a very simple
training a big VM I could be running the
same the same training in a GPU VM to of
course to improve my time so the answer
yeah bring in your any framework and you
have a infrastructure like GPUs on
demand which is very interesting you
just use it for a few hours and you spin
it down which is a big big cost
effective I noticed that when you are
running this your cuyps
your constant complaint there's all no
internet which is slows down your
process so is it true that this
Microsoft ire will I sure will
heavily depend on internet connection so
there's only one there's only one
version which is cloud version right
yeah so I think we need to have better
internet connection for sure when our
test is at home or in my laptop in the
office this morning it works perfectly
so I think it's just if you have low low
latency of course you experiment that
but you're right that's accessible
through the public Internet of course
that's that's the minute you with cloud
computing in general machine not just
the machine learning capabilities I
showed you the example you can start in
your laptop but to get all these
capabilities doing automated machine
learning your experiments leverage
appears of course you need to have some
connection to get to the end point but
that's just what you should expect to
get on your work yes another question is
a bit challenging offer with hope you
can handle it
so for example our company have already
two kind of software's or what is
offered a global deal one is cloud era
data science workbench so it's
completely based on Juvenal book or
scala and also supported by the big data
infrastructure another is a ripen minor
so basically one version for non-coding
people another version for hardcore data
scientist so the scenes that you know
every company have their own deal what
is your comparative advantage compared
to cannot era or rapid miner so firstly
color is a big partner of Microsoft for
long
time and these customers were running
closer large clusters on top of Escher
so I would not say it's just either one
or the other one I think if you are
existing dollar investments with happy
parties you were happy to leverage that
in the cloud the good fact is that you
will be able to scale up your cluster or
shut it down that's already a big
advantage second thing I'll say is we've
been able using with some of the
features I write we've been investing
art to bring cutting-edge features such
as a graphical experience for
non-professional a design this open
source sdk for any framework automated
machine learning and a few other things
that a machine and that so those ones I
think they are very differentiated it
has been done at probably the last five
years in the market so I think you have
the open to choose both and I have
customers using both which i think is
also a sweet spot so thank you for a
great presentation thank you yeah I've
never used any automated mo tools but
I'm curious how do you handle type a
parameter tuning for these kind of
automated tools yes so I didn't go too
much into detail there's three ways you
can use Auto ml the one you you've seen
sorry I cannot see you but hopefully you
can hear me the first one is the basic
when you've seen is a graphical one so
it's allows you to choose a few things
not more you don't go to a lot of detail
into the AI parameters it's just really
to get started the second way to consume
it which of course is the one I prefer
is using SDK so that case you're coding
a little bit so you're specifying a lot
more parameters to a function which
might be the definition of all you want
to play with type our parameters in the
third way is basically on power bi which
is even more business user oriented
which you just basically take what you
want to predict and what other variables
and does everything for you so you have
the two ways from very basic and to
sophisticated meaning into code level
but still automate what happens beyond
listen thank you for speech have you
test the after mail for example in Cal
competitions to achieve what the
accuracy of the you're after main models
and yes does myself Microsoft after main
engine it's a great question I don't
know I'm sure people have tried it's
it's actually just been out for a few
months I wanted to show something
cutting it but it came for
probably some people it's interesting to
compare with goggles yeah as a result
sent to what is the accuracy oh yeah
completely I think it's a great idea
sure next you might say you'll see some
blog posts of people doing that
[Music]